John Boehner he's the speaker the house
he's a very very
orange man and guess what he is suing
President Obama that's right he has had
it
with these executive actions that
basically the republicans have forced
President Obama to take
because they won't allow him to get any
legislation to his desk to sign
and now I they're saying he's
overreaching so bainer is
actually forming a lawsuit to sue the
president over this
and the present Obama is not too happy
about it we've got some video
you know the soon as a spot but what I
toll sticker better directly years
if you're really concerned about me
taken too many
executive actions
why don't you try getting something done
through congress
the majority American people wanna see
immigration reform done
we had a bipartisan bill through the
Senate and you're gonna swap
here hi try fix some parts of the
administratively
that are within my authority why you are
not doing okay so
just be very clear: what's happening
here the republicans are not giving him
any legislation to signs that he's
trying
to take power with which is within his
rights
even though I talk a lot about how I'm
not for the executive actions and I
believe in separation
a powers and all that but they're pretty
much giving him no choice he seemed
pretty pissed there for Obama
that's actually pretty personally think
I agree well he's right that it's a
stunt
and it's got nothing to do with him its
all about the fact that john bainer
knows how deeply the Tea Party hates him
and this is nothing more than a craven
pleaded the Tea Party to respect him
by doing something disgusting Obama has
had
significantly fewer I executive orders
at the president bush which never
bothered anyone
yeah and it's literally like 20 percent
yeah
you know this is but this is aging are
just whole thing he's got nothing going
he has no legislative agenda
no legislative agenda whatsoever and
this is why when they wanna talk about
Obama having a low approval rating well
congress has a low approval rating than
media I
Canadian I get five hundred dollar 50
had a consensus fun getting there
I suppose to John Mayer so this is all
look when when they were voting
last year on the speaker of the house
should be they were singing
several rather conspicuous protest vote
against
speaker bainer louie Gohmert actually
voted
forearm for once a space the lunatic Ted
Cruz
no not a cruise the Allen West Virginia
Tech this hell yeah
Alamosa so kids historian flushed itself
down the toilet 140 that God
without a job there yeah Gohmert voted
for guy who'd been voted out of congress
to be the speaker of the house
over a speaker bainer he knows how
deeply unpopular he is
the his biggest ally was Eric Cantor who
wanted his job
this is John beaners desperation showing
through and it's not gonna make the Tea
Party I like him anymore
and that really did work after Eric
Cantor so before we get into too much to
the political my to share this did you
know that they can even sue the
president
doesn't seem like the worst possible
eckhard government so dysfunctional
and by the way I you can see the present
when you when I'm seeing
I'm seeing better being desperate times
about me angry and I think the best way
to solve this is with reality television
had to have a GD time show when I would
absolute support a stunt like that if I
can't watch it play out on TV
yeah is what do we do about this because
this is saying we talk about every week
on this that just the branches of
government no longer work
that Obama is being forced in the
morning they were kidnapped the sound
like I'm in a room but they work if you
work at it
right but with the concert that we have
now just we did with that
republicans are being held hostage by
the tea party like it's just nothing's
working
so what do we do to make this work
instead of going to the idiotic lawsuits
and forcing the president and to do
things that a lot of people don't want
to do an upcoming
well I mean this is Obama's Making Work
that's what he's doing this the American
people don't wanna sit around
you know complain about the government
they want the government to do stuff for
them
but it is in the interest of the GOP to
make government as weak as possible
they serve the CEO's the struggle our
country is never been
conservative versus liberal its
aristocracy bursa democracy
and a Disney interest %uh the upper 1
percent
the upper point to 1 percent evil half
the key government for working and I
find interesting the same people who are
trying to weaken government
here are complaining that other
countries your government is weak
I love aline is a tweeted earlier its
you know exactly what they do
day one they're getting exactly what
they want they want the gridlock they
want nothing to happen
because it government works that means
democracy works in a democracy works
that means the people are gonna run this
country and that is not in the interest
of these
vassals the Koch brothers so going to
your reality show point should we have
more cameras around
what's going on really is. do remember
during the Obamacare debate
even present Obama said we will have
this all open to everybody will aired on
c-span
of course not if that happened I'd and I
think the Democrats don't wanna just as
much as the republicans the one
so really shouldn't we had not been as
me realize you were moaning people of
all I think that's pretty good idea
worship which is more cameras around so
some other stuff is actually true or at
least a really well made Netflix
documentary
I mean a change I have mine on Romney
that and come out passion
things on a bomb there that I got that
the documentary was metal baseball glove
and how to be more interesting out on
you your eye to eye I think the Supreme
Court
should be on television I think student
I think classrooms
I think public school classrooms should
be on the internet I think executions
should be televised we're paying for it
I will in televised executions use
seeded No the numbers on death penalty
sleep overnight
so you think you would go down I think
again so suggesting they might actually
go
people who go to church call themselves
Christians despite the fact that Jesus
quite clearly spoke out against killing
the center
he never mentioned birth control never
mentioned abortion never mentioned gay
people
its began about killing the center
rather specifically if these people saw
the murder that their tax dollars pay
for and by the way
I like that they don't consider it
murder if the state doesn't have to get
more big government is scrapping died
when tabling poisoning in the death
right and doing it for our viewers yes
although sometimes the guy that's
actually doing the poisoning or the
electrocution really doesn't even know
because they have them but I think
taxpayers have a right to see
as much up what they pay for as possible
that doesn't jeopardize national
security
yeah are televised case actually know
what they're missing out on
we did that the next step in the gay
rights movement is televising a sec
sorry guys Datamonitor on porn sites
you'd rather